[Music]
let's talk about this uh i'm out here
for a lot of guests i rarely see a
reaction like that you were on fire the
last couple of years you've always been
amazingly funny and talented but super
bowl ads hit tv shows you hosted saturn
at live
and then you just won a grammy for best
spoken word album which is fantastical
this boss bless your heart ask me and
you won't i mean did you think you were
up against tina fey for this you brought
oh well nobody's up against tina tina's
in a class by herself but i tell you
something
it's just at 90 years old i was not
expecting this let's put it that way
just the way things have gone the last
couple of years has been just fantastic
that's right so i'm going to start lying
about my age
i'm 45. you're 45.
wow
you know how it works in this town don't
you i don't i do you want this job
you just had your 90th birthday and how
many performers get to say that
president obama sent a personal message
to you a video message do you believe
that i didn't believe it until i saw it
can we show it right now oh yes yes this
is the president sending you a video
hold on
dear betty
you look so fantastic and full of energy
i can't believe you're 90 years old
in fact
i don't believe it
that's why i'm writing to ask if you
will be willing to produce a copy of
your long-form birth certificate
very good
that was very funny
it just blew me away and we had nobody
out here had anything to do with that
that was all done in washington yeah can
you imagine the president taking time to
do that i'm sure there's a lot of
serious crises breaking out while he was
making that little sense well he was
doing that yes but you know first things
first
the stock market crashed that day but oh
well